Mais, comprenez-moi bien !
Je réalise parfaitement l'importance du rituel,
tout spécialement lorsqu'il s'agit des gens que nous aimons.
Mais, nous devons être capables de créer et de pratiquer ce rituel
sans porter préjudice à l'environnement.
C'est pour cette raison que nous avons besoin de nouvelles options.
Donc, retournons à l'idée de protection, désinfection et embellissement.
Commençons par le corps mort.
L'industrie funéraire va protéger votre dépouille
en offrant de vendre à votre famille un cercueil en bois ou en métal,
avec un produit d'étanchéité à base de caoutchouc.
Au cimetière, le jour de l'enterrement, ce cercueil va être descendu
dans une large tombe en béton ou en métal.
Nous gaspillons toutes ces ressources, - béton, métal, bois -
en les dissimulant dans de vastes forteresses souterraines.
Quand vous choisissez d'être enterré au cimetière,
votre dépouille est loin d'être en contact avec la terre qui l'entoure.
De la nourriture pour les vers ? Vous n'en êtes pas du tout.
Ensuite, l'industrie va désinfecter votre corps
par l'embaumement : la conservation chimique du mort.
Cette procédure draine votre sang
et le remplace par du formaldéhyde, toxique et cancérigène.
Ils disent qu'ils font cela pour la santé publique
parce qu'un corps mort peut être dangereux,
mais les docteurs, présents dans cette pièce, vous diront
que cette allégation ne s'applique que si la personne est morte
d'une maladie extrêmement contagieuse, telle qu'Ebola.
Même la décomposition humaine,
- qui, en toute honnêteté, est plutôt malodorante et désagréable -
est parfaitement sans danger.
La bactérie qui entraîne une maladie
n'est pas la même que la bactérie responsable de la décomposition.
Finalement, l'industrie va embellir la dépouille.
Ils vont vous dire que la dépouille naturelle de votre père ou mère
n'est pas assez bien telle qu'elle est.
Ils vont lui mettre du maquillage,
la revêtir d'un costume,
lui injecter des colorants afin que la personne ait l'air plus vivante
et simplement en train de se reposer.
L'embaumement est une tricherie
donnant l'illusion que la mort puis la décomposition
ne sont pas la fin naturelle de toute vie organique sur cette planète.
Si ce système d'embellissement, désinfection et protection
ne vous plaît pas, vous n'êtes pas les seuls.
Il existe toute une flopée de gens
- entrepreneurs funéraires, designers, écologistes -
qui essaient de créer une façon plus écologique de traiter le mort.
Pour ces gens, la mort n'est pas nécessairement
le smoking bleu-pastel et le parfait maquillage.
Il ne fait aucun doute que nos méthodes actuelles de traitement du mort
ne sont pas particulièrement écologiques
avec le gaspillage des ressources et notre recours aux produits chimiques.
Même la crémation,
généralement considérée comme l'option respectueuse de l'environnement,
utilise, par crémation,
l'équivalent en gaz naturel d'un trajet en voiture de 800 km.
Donc, quoi faire de tout ça ?
L'été dernier, j'étais dans les montagnes de la Caroline du Nord,
transportant des seaux de copeaux de bois, sous le soleil d'été.
J'étais à l'Université Western Carolina, à leur « ferme des corps »,
plus exactement appelée : un « centre de décomposition humaine ».
Les corps donnés à la science y sont apportés
et leur décomposition est étudiée
pour contribuer au développement de la médecine légale.
Ce jour-là, douze corps étaient exposés
dans différents états de décomposition.
Certains étaient à l'état de squelettes.
L'un d'entre eux portait un pyjama violet.
Une barbe blonde était encore visible sur un autre.
L'aspect médico-légal est vraiment fascinant,
mais ce n'était pas la raison pour laquelle j'étais là.
J'étais là parce qu'une de mes collègues, Katrina Spade,
tente de créer un système non pas d'incinération des morts,
mais de compostage des morts.
Elle appelle ce système « Recomposition » et nous l'utilisons avec les bovins
et autres animaux d'élevage depuis des années.
Elle imagine un établissement où la famille pourrait venir
et déposer leur proche décédé dans un mélange riche en nutriments
qui, en l'espace de quatre à six semaines,
réduirait le corps - os et tout le reste -, en terreau.
Durant ces quatre à six semaines, vos molécules deviennent d'autres molécules.
Vous vous transformez, littéralement.
Comment cela s'accorderait-il avec le désir très récent
qui semble partagé par beaucoup, d'être enterré sous un arbre
ou de devenir un arbre à leur mort ?
Dans une crémation traditionnelle, les cendres
- des fragments d'os inorganiques -
forment une couche calcaire épaisse,
qui, à moins d'être distribuée comme il faut dans la terre,
peut, en fait, nuire à l'arbre ou le tuer.
Mais si vous êtes recomposés, si vous devenez véritablement du terreau,
vous pouvez nourrir l'arbre
et devenir le contributeur post-mortem que vous avez toujours rêvé d'être,
et que vous méritez d'être.
Ceci est donc une option pour le futur de la crémation.
Mais qu'en est-il du futur des cimetières ?
Beaucoup de gens pensent que les cimetières ne devraient plus exister
parce que nous manquons de terrains.
Mais... Et si nous les redéfinissions ?
Et si le cadavre n'était pas l'ennemi de la terre,
mais son éventuel sauveur ?
Je parle du cimetière de conservation
où de vastes étendues de terre sont achetées par une fiducie foncière.
Sa beauté, c'est qu'une fois que quelques corps sont plantés sur ce terrain,
on ne peut ni le toucher, ni y construire,
d'où le terme « cimetière de conservation ».
C'est comme si vous vous enchaîniez à un arbre après votre mort,
« Non, je ne partirai pas !
Non, vraiment, je ne peux pas. Je me décompose là-dessous. »
(Rires)
L'argent donné au cimetière par la famille
servirait à protéger et gérer le terrain.
Il n'y a ni pierre tombale ni tombe au sens traditionnel du terme.
Les tombes sont éparpillées sur la propriété
sous des tertres élégants,
marquées seulement par une pierre ou un petit disque en métal,
ou parfois repérables uniquement par G.P.S.
Il n'y a pas d'embaumement,
pas de lourds cercueils en métal.
Mon entreprise funéraire vend quelques cercueils
en matériaux comme l'osier tressé et le bambou,
mais honnêtement, la plupart des familles choisissent simplement un linceul.
On n'y trouve pas les grands caveaux que la plupart des cimetières demandent
juste parce qu'ils leur permettent d'aménager le site plus facilement.
Les familles peuvent venir là. Elles peuvent jouir de la nature.
Elles peuvent même planter un arbre ou un arbuste.
Cependant, seules les plantes originaires de la région sont admises.
Alors, les morts se fondent harmonieusement dans le paysage.
Les cimetières de conservation sont porteurs d'espoir.
Ils offrent un endroit réservé aux espaces verts dans les zones urbaines et rurales.
Ils offrent la possibilité de réintroduire
des plantes et des animaux indigènes, dans une région.
Ils offrent des sentiers publics, des lieux de pratique spirituelle,
des sites pour des classes et des événements,
et des endroits où nature et deuil se rencontrent...
Surtout, ils nous offrent de nouveau une chance
de nous décomposer tout simplement dans un trou dans le sol.
La terre,
permettez-moi de vous le dire,
souffre de notre absence.
Je crois que beaucoup commencent à avoir le sentiment
que notre industrie funéraire actuelle ne leur convient pas vraiment.
Pour beaucoup d'entre nous, être désinfecté et embelli ne nous reflète pas.
Cela ne reflète pas ce que nous avons défendu durant notre vie.
Est-ce que changer la façon d'enterrer nos morts
résoudra le changement climatique ?
Non.
Mais cela créera des avancées audacieuses
dans notre regard sur nous-mêmes en tant que citoyens de cette planète.
Si nous pouvons mourir d'une façon plus humble et consciente de nous-mêmes,
je crois qu'il nous reste une chance de le faire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)